linda was primarily about students and
young scientists meeting Nobel laureates
this event turning the tables we're
reversing that this is an opportunity
for the laureates to meet and questioned
some students this week I don't know
whether anyone saw saw this a prominent
scientists describe PhD students as
serfs which is somewhat controversial so
my question is to the panel is your
experience that you have been treated
like a surf and what should the
relationship between a student and the
supervisor v I'm proud to be a surf I'm
proud to be the labor of science because
for me my supervisor is more delegating
to things and I'm the one who's doing
the research writing the codes writing
the papers so from this respect from a
labor respect I believe we are deserves
but it is a good thing I mean that's why
I'm in science and I wouldn't give that
up you can come work for me anytime I
see I think for a scientist is very
important to be to feel like freedom and
independence sometimes I see people that
are working many many hours but they
stopped to enjoy very soon and they just
give data experiments results but no
ideas and no no happiness that's
important i think i think the
interaction between supervisor and the
student has to be a very close one but
there has to be an element of freedom
and to find things that are interesting
for you and be able to follow them
through without the supervisor telling
you it is a stupid idea and it might be
a stupid idea but out of stupid ideas
come to the most brilliant solid
breakthroughs so I say you know look
stupid to me but do it because I know
I'm stupid as well do any of you guys
have negative experiences about the fact
that you're on the road so much or that
you're not in good contact with your
students I was feel that
you're doing with a student is you're
bringing them through this transition as
a graduate student as a postdoc where
they're going to become independent
researchers themselves and the more you
can be independent the more you can give
them confidence that you give them
guidance but if they think they did it
all themselves and they don't know why
you're even their mentor but you
actually did a good job because you give
them confidence that they're going to be
able to go forward and do the research
and some some students do that extremely
well it's very natural for some students
actually want their handheld and it's
difficult when you're traveling a lot
when you're an international student as
I think you will what are the criteria
does it does internationality figure in
your choice of the next job that you
apply for after a while you became you
become stateless it has its advantages
and it has its disadvantages and you
become ready to move anywhere possible
because you want to do the thing you
want to do but then you cannot really
settle which is not so pleasant if
you're looking for a career some
countries are a little bit behind in the
infrastructure and and some of the
people very talented the are actually
brain draining their countries by not
coming back internationality has it's
different size and russia the same i
just visited moscow and and people are
complaining a non-stop it's not ideal
now in Russia as far as science support
is going yeah it's completely my case
I'm I moved basically because a in
Russia I had to do my PhD and at the
same time I was working as a full-time
teacher at school at a state school and
of course it takes a lot of energy these
teenagers you know three sided days for
nine hours and i also have a small
daughter in the units so the rest or
like 10 hours per week i was spending
for sales that's not enough I'm from
Norway I grew up in Norway was a
mechanical engineer for Norman is
upstate in Norway I was
will be a mechanical engineer so
sometimes you have to go abroad to do
example and I know you don't seem like
you like to see you I want to see my
decision because I liked MIT a lot and I
thought that it will add to me a lot and
then I had to consider you know whether
is why we provide me enough good enough
infrastructure that I'll be able to
continue maybe not on the level of MIT
but on a good enough level and in
retrospect it was the right decision but
understand the considerations and they
are very very sensitive I think the
bigger question is not just going back
to our native countries but to be able
to stay at one place when you need to do
so many postdocs to get into the tenure
there because the market has become much
tougher at my time we used to do one of
three four years and finished when you
got your first assistant professorship
which typically was stereo track so if
you manage you cross the tenure barrier
and then that's it and you're on the
faculty nowadays you're absolutely right
it becomes more and more difficult you
have to wonder around with many postdocs
and resettle and people have families
like and it becomes difficult to dispose
yes we realize what are you guys most
concerned about right now so from buyers
we're hearing he's concerned about how
is he going to land and build a life
because he's really good to build the
rest of his life he's found the
scientific opportunity now he wants to
find the life opportunity is that is
that the most serious concern you guys
have it's not I'd say my biggest concern
all they have to do outside of science
and those who have a lot of political
science politicians and I I think that
we should have more politicians who have
in scientists before does anyone here
have the nerve to consider a career in
politics yeah I have visited a career in
politics but I have also stopped
considering your curry Louisa throughout
why why it's not like science there is
no search for truth it's actually kind
of a search for the best most saleable
why and I don't like that as much I'm
not very good at why I shouldn't
beautiful way to you but scientific
method can be used politics can be done
because there is some kind of a reality
if your concern
about people and if your comments that
the cause is this and that because of
this data then I think it could be done
it's well it is necessary there's no
there's no doubt that it's your society
does need to have some people
interacting the problem is the interface
between say the philosophy that really
gives based on evidence and we see that
specifically in the case of say climate
change where there's this massive
political backlash against the
scientific community because they just
do not understand the how science works
in democratic societies the politicians
like it base what they say and they're
saying people want to hear if you give
you put a scientist into politics and
stood up there and said we're all doomed
you know climate change is good he were
going to left it the problem is
encapsulated by Truman who was
responsible for dropping the bomb on
Hiroshima and he said give me a wall
mount scientist was that and they can't
say on the other hand and it
encapsulates a problem because no one
has used the products of science more
effectively if you wish and true that
was a very that was something that the
scientific you materially when
tremendous root deep problems with
because they didn't realize it wasn't
built for that particular purpose on
what they didn't work for that
particular purpose but I wanted to say
that I think the interaction of science
and politics is really important I've
taken a little bit of my Nobel money to
start summer internships for physics
students to work with the politicians
that we have in Washington that we have
three legislators who are physicists
actually and so I think it's possible
although some people doubted that a
scientist could be a good politician I
think some of them are and I actually
chipped in to help elect one of those
physicists so I thought this is really
cool he worked at Fermilab and he's a
good scientist so I think as a point
that I advise people not to give up too
easily and I perfectly well think I'm
not a good politician I'm I'm saying
that's I
have the right personality but some
people do and I want people to take this
as a serious possibility I think we
shouldn't burden them too much I mean we
heard that they are really involved in
basic problems of where to settle how to
develop their career I think that the
only thing is one not to be cynical
because the politicians are important
they represent the public they are
elected by the public and we are living
in the public we are living on the
taxpayers money at the end of the day
and the politicians decide about the
fate of science and higher education so
the idea is really not to be cynical
doesn't mean that we have to be involved
in politics and the idea for you i think
is to be a word about the interfaces i
don't think that you really we need to
ask you now to go to politics when you
haven't even graduated and you have to
think of your postdoc in your position
and the grants and and furthermore but
to be a word that there are many
interfaces between science and society
so being aware of it putting it in the
back of your minds I think that this is
the right way to do it I think the
easiest way for us to affect politics is
to communicate and to educate right
because that is the easiest way for
individuals to influence their
politicians and pressure definitely
changes well a couple of years ago they
were immediately change in the
government the government started a
series of cuts on budgets to the
university's basically students with the
professors and we decided to give a
series of lessons in the squares of the
city we were in front of the dome of
malaya and there were a lot of people
that stopped at there just to listen to
what we were doing but it was very very
nice to see that when we move away from
our buildings when we go in in the
middle of the squares that people is
interested in we have a similar
experience yesterday with the people of
lindau there were a lot of families and
they started to interact
them to speak with them and and you can
see that they were happy to talk with us
we started to speak about sides and then
we we move on speaking about our lives
our culture's and so on I mean it was a
dream yesterday on that note thank you
all for attending thank you to the
students thank you to the laureates